bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous
sur arte france comment interpréter le
lancement de cette centaines de
centrifugeuses à natanz en pleines
discussions sur l'accord de vienne
il s'agit d'un jeu de tactique de
pression n'est ce pas de part et d'autre
de la table à vous avez donc les
iraniens qui viennent de faire cette
annonce il y avait eu d'autre part des
attaques sur des sites saoudien a donc
de la part des outils au yémen soutenu
par téhéran
donc vous avez un jeu n'est ce pas de
pression vis-à-vis de l'autre camp
occidental à qui lui même mais des
pressions aussi sur téhéran n'oublions
pas à les attaques qui ont eu lieu en
iran sur des installations industrielles
et même nucléaire à la teinte est aussi
l'élimination à d'un haut responsable du
département de la la défense fakhrizadeh
au mois de novembre donc il y à des
pressions et d'autres pas chaque parti
dit ce n'est pas à moi de faire le
premier pas c'est à vous de le faire
alors ce n'est pas le calendrier n'est
pas hasardeux puisqu'aujourd'hui en
errance et la journée nationale de la
technologie nucléaire est ce qu'on peut
dire une certaine façon que cette
inauguration par le président hassan
rohani c'est un démonstration de force
de la part de téhéran aux deux forces
est un bien grand mot vous savez là on
parle de quelques 160 centrifugeuses
dont une grande partie ne sont là que en
termes d'installation et non pas
d'opération et avant l'accord à de 2015
dv 19 1000 centrifugeuses en actions
dont vous voyez vous il y à un grand
écart ce n'est pas vraiment une pression
c'est beaucoup de communication à qui
évite de parler des choses importantes
en iran qui sont par exemple la
situation économique a qui sont allés
potentiel deux cent cinquante mille
morts a annoncé par la résistance
iranienne
à part le coville 19 en iran a qui sont
les manifestations à des retraités des
manifestations de la jeunesse a donc il
ya un malaise social et toute cette
démonstration a donc autour du nucléaire
et elle fait aussi pour mettre un voile
pudique sur la situation intérieure
alors c'est vrai que les tests sur ces
nouvelles centrifugeuses vont à
l'encontre en tout cas des engagements
pris par téhéran
c'est interdit donc par l'accord a
enseigné en vienne en 2015 cela signifie
quoi pour la suite des pourparlers qui
sont en cours avec les signataires du
pacte de vienne en vue d'une dinde d'un
d'une potentielle réintégration des
états unis toute façon il va falloir du
temps vous savez où vous faites
référence à 2015 les négociations pour
aboutir à l'accord du 14 juillet 2015
ont démarré fin 2012 début 2013
dans voyez-vous il a fallu beaucoup de
temps pour créer l'accord maintenant il
s'agit de réintégrer l'accord ou de
revenir aux éléments qui ont déjà été
définis mais il y a à l'évidence un
nécessité de plusieurs mois de
négociations
est ce qui est très important et à
nouveau il faut revenir c'est la
situation intérieure iranienne
c'est dans quelques semaines au mi juin
il y à des élections présidentielles
n'est ce pas à en iran donc que va-t-il
se passer à comment la population qui
est en proie au chômage et à la baisse
de son pouvoir d'achat depuis des années
va réagir
ae et tout cela est un élément aussi de
la situation globale iranienne juste cet
accord sur le nucléaire
que signifie qu'il pourra l'opinion
publique iranienne
je crois que les si vous écoutez les
cris dans les manifestations à mon sens
pour l'iran pas pour la syrie n'est ce
pas les iraniens à ne donne pas
confiance oro au régime pour les actions
extérieures il ya une crise économique
où le pays demande des investissements
et une amélioration due
niveau de vie intérieure donc le la
puissance à l'intervention extérieure
régionales
ce sont des axes des objectifs du régime
mais pas de la population iranienne qui
veut à comme l'on dit du poulet et du
riz dans son assiette alors l'iran
demande la levée des sanctions
américaines les états unis de leur côté
demande à téhéran de faire plus
d'efforts
est ce que il y aura ici n'est une
réintégration de washington dans cet
accord a fait c'est possible mais comme
je viens de le lire je crois qu'il faut
faire très attention au temps qui va
s'écouler les prochaines semaines sont
clés à l'intérieur de l'iran qu'est ce
qui va se passer
ah c'est vraiment à ce moment là qu'elle
va être l'option du nouveau président
quel va être ce nouveau président donc
il ya ces éléments intérieurs qui sont
vraiment je crois prête aussi important
que les éléments extérieurs à savoir la
la position de bruxelles où la position
de washington
merci gérard de pierre on va donc
surveiller de près la situation en
interne en iran où je rappelle qu est le
fondateur du webmagazine le monde
décrypté 6